so I'd like to tell you a story about
climate and change but it's really a
story about people and not polar bears
so this is our house that we lived in in
the mid 2000 I was the chief operating
officer for the Navy's weather and ocean
service they happened to be down at a
place called Stennis Space Center right
on the Gulf Coast so we lived in a
little town called Waveland Mississippi
nice modest house and as you can see
it's up against the storm surge now if
you ever wonder what a 30-foot or nine
meters storm surge does coming up your
street let me show you same house
that's me kind of wondering what's next
but when we say we lost our house this
is like right after Katrina so the house
is either all the way up there in the
railway tracks or it's somewhere down
there in the Gulf of Mexico and to this
day we really we lost our house we don't
know where it is yeah yeah it's it's
gone so I don't show this for pity
because we in many ways we were
the luckiest people on the Gulf Coast
one of the things is we had insurance
and kind of that idea of insurance is
probably pretty pretty important there
but does this scale up you know what
happened here and I think it kind of
does because as you've heard that as the
sea levels come up it takes weaker and
weaker storms to do something like this
so let's just step back for a second and
kind of look at this and you don't climb
it's really complicated a lot of moving
parts in this but I kind of put it about
it's all about the water so you see
those three blue dots there down on the
lower part the one you can easily see
that's all the water in the world those
two smaller dots those are the
freshwater and it turns out that as the
climate changes the distribution of that
water is changing very fundamentally so
now we have too much too little wrong
place wrong time the salty where it
should be
fresh its liquid where it should be
frozen it's wet where it should be dry
and in fact the very chemistry of the
ocean itself is changing what that does
from a security or a military part is is
it does three things it changes a very
operating environment that we're working
in it threatens our bases and then it
has geo strategic risks which sounds
kind of fancy in it and I'll explain
what I mean by that in in a second so
let's go to just a couple examples here
and we'll start off with what we all
know is of course a political and
humanitarian catastrophe that is Syria
and it turns out that climate was one of
one of the causes in a long chain of
events it actually started back in the
1970s when Assad took control over Syria
he decided he wanted to be
self-sufficient in things like wheat and
barley now you would like to think that
there was somebody in Assad's office who
said hey boss you know we're in the
eastern Mediterranean kind of dry here
maybe not the best idea but I think what
happened was boss you are a smart
powerful and handsome man
we'll get right on it and they did so by
the 90s believe it or not they were
actually self-sufficient in food but
they did it at a great cost they did it
a cost of their aquifers they did it a
cost of their surface water and of
course there are many non climate issues
that also contributed to Syria there is
the Iraq war and as you can see by that
lower blue line there over a million
refugees come into the cities and then
about a decade ago there is this
tremendous heatwave and drought
fingerprints all over that show yes this
is in fact related to the changing
climate has put another 3/4 of a million
farmers into those same cities why
because they had nothing they had dust
they had dirt they had nothing so now
they're in the cities the Iraqis are in
the cities its Assad it's not like he's
taking care of his people and all of a
sudden we have just this huge issue here
of massive instability and a breeding
ground for
and this is why in the security
community we call climate change is a
risk to instability it accelerates
instability here in plain English it
makes bad places worse so let's go to
another place here now we're gonna go
2,000 kilometers or about 1200 miles
north of Oslo only 600 miles from the
pole and this is arguably the most
strategic island you've never heard of
its place called Svalbard it sits
astride the sea lanes that the Russian
Northern Fleet needs to get out and go
into warmer waters it is also by virtue
of its geography a place where you can
control every single polar orbiting
satellite on every orbit it is the
strategic high ground of space climate
change has greatly reduced the sea ice
around here greatly increasing human
activity and it's becoming a flashpoint
and in fact the NATO Parliamentary
Assembly is going to meet here on
Svalbard next month the Russians are
very very unhappy about that so if you
want to find a flashpoint in the Arctic
look at Svalbard there now in the
military we have known for decades if
not centuries at the time to prepare
whether it's for a hurricane a typhoon
or strategic changes is before they hit
you and Admiral Nimitz was right there
that is the time to prepare
fortunately our secretary of defense
secretary mattis he understands that as
well and what he understands is that
climate is a risk he has said so in his
written responses to Congress and he
says as Secretary of Defense it's my job
to manage such risks it's not only the
US military that understands this many
of our friends and allies in other
navies and other militaries have very
clear-eyed views about the climate risk
and in fact in 2014 I was honored to
speak for a half-a-day seminar at the
international sea power symposium 270
heads of navies about this issue so
Winston Churchill is alleged to have
said I'm not sure if he said anything
but he's alleged to have said that
Americans can always be counted upon to
do the right thing after exhausting
every other possibility
I would argue we're still in the process
of exhausting every other possibility
but I do think we will prevail but I
need your help
this is my ask I ask not that you take
your recycling out on Wednesday but that
you engage with every business leader
every technology leader every government
leader and ask them ma'am sir what are
you doing to stabilize the climate it's
just that simple
because when enough people care enough
the politicians most of whom won't lead
on this issue but they will be led that
will change this because I can tell you
the ice doesn't care the ice doesn't
care who's in the White House it doesn't
care which party controls your Congress
it doesn't care which party controls
your Parliament it just melts thank you
very much
[Applause]